sagen sie einmal ganz kurz nur 50
prozent der pflegenden wie wie kann das
sein
ich würde sagen das entspricht
eigentlich der bevölkerung wenn sie in
ihrem bekanntenkreis herum frage sagt
jeder jeden nächstes jahr wird besser
lässt du dich denn auch impfen dann
erstmal nicht und wir haben überwiegend
junge leute in den pflegeheimen die
natürlich teilweise sehr verunsichert
waren durch eventuelle schwangerschaft
etc
was da alles geschrieben worden ist und
ja auch teilweise sehr offensiv gebracht
worden ist verstehe ich die
verunsicherung menschen die eben etwas
nicht kennen etwas nicht wissen sind
zunächst einfach ganz normal das sage
ich mal als arzt der auch viel
psychologisch betreut
ist es normal dass man erst mal
zurückschreckt und ich nicht hatte das
jetzt nicht sehr verwundert dass wir
erst mal nur 50 prozent aber heute mit
dem klinikum gesprochen klinikum essen
die corvette patienten haben da ist eine
86 prozentige bereitschaft sich impfen
zu lassen
aber die wii nicht so unmittelbar
betroffen sind sind eher mal
zurückhaltend was bedeutet das aber für
die kommenden monate für das ganze jahr
wären pfleger sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen wenn der großteil der bewohner
trotzdem geimpft ist es dann nicht mehr
ganz so dramatisch dass es trotzdem eine
entwicklung die in sorge bereitet
zunächst mal ist ja politisch gewollt
dass die über 80-jährigen als erste
geimpft werden sollte das wird jetzt zur
zeit erfolgen in essen hoffen wir dass
wir das schaffen die pflegeheime bis zum
fünfzehnten des monats geimpft so haben
wir haben 76 heime allein in essen
das ist jetzt erstmal frage des
impfstoffs tiefe kommt an
natürlich jeder der geimpft ist ist
einer der weniger auch übertragen kann
ich hätte persönlich wahrscheinlich
sogar eher die pflegen denn ein erster
stelle geschrieben und auch das
klinikpersonal an erster stelle
aber das war jetzt der politische wille
und ich meine wir haben jetzt ein jahr
mit corona gekämpft jetzt kommt
eigentlich auf ein paar tage sage ich
mal auch nicht mehr unbedingt an
wir müssen weiter alle maßnahmen ein
abstandsregeln maske usw das wird uns
weiter verfolgen und ich hoffe schon
dass wir bis zum juni die sache im griff
haben und zwar sehe ich das auch so wir
haben jetzt einen impfstoff in
deutschland der schwierig in handling
ist wenn wir den moderner im stoff zum
beispiel kommen der am 6
wohl auch nach europa kommt dann können
ja auch die hausärzte mit einsteigen und
vor ort impfen
und da sehe ich so die möglichkeit die
kollegen haben vor ort 20 millionen
grippeimpfung in zwei monaten geschafft
warum sollen sie nicht die komik impfung
auch schaffen und ich denke mal da wird
auch die bereitschaft größer sein sich
impfen zu lassen von dem arzt den mann
kennen lerne impfpflicht macht ja die
skeptiker nicht unbedingt überzeugen
dass die sich impfen lassen und ich
würde nicht mit dem druck arbeiten
wollen sondern eher mit einer
vernünftigen aufklärung
ich bin selber morgen in einem weiteren
heim tätig das sich selber aufgeklärt
habe ich bin extra hingefahren habe eine
fragestunde gemacht habe gefragt wie
sieht es aus und ich hoffe dass ich in
diesen pflegeheim morgen ich bin sehr
gespannt
eine impfquote habe die deutlich über
diesen 50 prozent liegt das liegt also
an der aufklärung letztendlich der
vertrauensperson aber auch aufklärung
insgesamt dass man eben nicht so eine
angst vor dieser impfung haben sollte
die ja eigentlich eine völlig harmlose
impfung ist sie ist neu aber sie ist
eigentlich von dem träger gar nicht so
ganz neu meine tochter ist selber
professor in san diego mit der ich also
auch regelmäßig in kontakt steht die
selber impfstoff entwickelt und die mir
ganz klar gesagt papa so eine einfache
impfung mit so wenig nebenwirkungen
findest du sonst nie wieder mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren